now from ottawa. Paula you spoke
with Trudeau. About China.
Specifically those suspected
Chinese spy blur. Yeah. I gotta
tell you, Jake. That's all
anyone can talk about in this
town in this country, for that
matter is Chinese interference,
interference and in so many
forms, not just the balloons and
quite frankly buoys that they
found in the arctic but also
more insidious kind of Chinese
surveillance, and that would
involve interference into
elections or even spying that is
going on in this country. Some
of it has implicated the Trudeau
government itself. They denied
that they had any knowledge of
this, but again, these are
thorny issues that, as Phil
said, president Biden and the
prime minister will be talking.
King about I want you to listen
now to what Justin Trudeau told
me about having to try and
balance. That Chinese
relationship listen. China we've
seen balloons in the air over
Canada. We've seen buoys in the
arctic. Um what do you think?
Are the Chinese motives in those
issues specifically, and what do
you hope to learn from the
Chinese balloon now in U. S
hands? Well, I think one of the
things we have to remember is
China is the second largest
economy in the world and
continues to grow. We are going
to have to in some circumstances
engage constructively with China
, like we did around the
conference and biodiversity that
we co hosted with them in
Montreal. There's issue. Use
around climate change that we
should be working as a world
together. There's other places
where we're going to have to be
stiff competition to China in
terms of market access in terms
of investments in the global
south, we need to be able to
show that the western
democracies are there to make
those investments and there is
competitive to China, but there
are also areas in which we're
going to have to directly
challenge China whether it's on
human rights, whether it's on
security behaviors, whether it's
on cyber attacks or concerns
like that we're going to have to
continue to be wide eyed and
clear about the threat that
China poses and wants to pose to
the stability of our
democracies. So I really want to
underscore those words. The
threat that China poses Jake
that extends to tiktok. The
prime minister has three kids.
Two teenagers at this point you